the day was great it's the 22nd of
october
22nd september today it's september oh
my god
the reason for why i'm saying that is
because i'm expecting a call one month
later
which is the 22nd of october so yeah
let's go back
wishing my life away so it's the 22nd of
what uh
again it's the 22nd of september today
and
today was mentoring
[Music]
so today we're working on my weaknesses
finding out where my sticking points are
with estate agents
and sort of working through them finding
out exactly
what i need to do to get over that to
get my deals coming a bit quicker today
was such a nice refresher course for me
i'm gonna book viewings to just make
relationships with estate agents
um so book appointments with estate
agents rather than just booking a
viewing and then just going around
reviewing and having quick chat with
them i'm actually gonna
sit down with them tell them what i'm
looking for actually spending that
one-on-one
intimate time with samuel on a level
where he can really
go over what i want to do and what i'm
good at and we've done that today it's
really good to get one-on-one mentoring
and actually sort of
reflect on exactly what i've sort of
been going through my journey so far you
probably can't
see but that the property that russell
moves at today
we all know sometimes we need to
physically see inspiration right so
so coming here today doing at russell's
house was was was inspiring in its own
right
i viewed a property last week and today
i've managed to actually secure the
property with
backing from samuel and confirming that
it's a good deal
rather than walking away because they
didn't take my first offer which i
thought was about right
but with a confirmation of end value it
turned out that actually i can offer
what they want for it
what we need to do is we need to
surround ourselves with like-minded
people
and sometimes in order to do that as
well we need to educate ourselves
and yeah we can do it with books and we
can do it on youtube
but sometimes we need to immerse
ourselves fully if we believe in
something
there's nothing better than proper
education and especially with people
that
are actually in it really enjoyed the
accelerating mentoring and coaching
program
because obviously we get a detailed talk
with samuel and
because there wasn't only two of us we
had a really good intimate talk with him
long time
throughout the whole day we spent a good
day with him had lunch and everything
i've really immersed myself with my work
and i haven't necessarily gone deep
with my property as well as i did as i
wanted to
um so yeah that's all on me though that
was all on me
but now we're gonna get on it get all
our questions in
get all our problems answered not just
get them answered but actually address
them with him
so he could guide us through our
problems and not just say here's your
problem
yeah we found it now go away and solve
it and come back and tell me how you got
on it was like
here's your problem now let's solve it
okay you didn't do it right
okay now try again let's solve it okay
that's better
and kept doing that property can be your
vehicle so if you want to live a life
of passive income or you want to help
people
to give them good properties um
property with the education in it it
gives you that vehicle
in order to to live that life and if
maybe you want to be a writer or if you
want to be something
and you can't um make money off that in
the beginning
if you start doing your properties and
you have passive income coming in
you have that freedom
you